Traduttore: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Beatrice Chiamenti
(Applausi)
Buon pomeriggio.
Ho deciso di iniziare
questa conversazione,
questa chacchierata con voi
scrivendo il mio indirizzo Twitter
perché la chiaccherata
è tra persone che sono vicine
come in questo caso, e tra persone
che sono da altre parti del mondo
ma che hanno voglia
di conversare con noi.
Io quando ero piccolo
non vedevo droni volare in cielo,
non c'erano bambini
che programmavano videogames
e questo gesto col dito lo facevo
al limite per metterlo
nel barattolo della Nutella
e per mangiare qualcosa.
Sono nato nel 1975,
da allora il mondo è cambiato
e ricambiato
e probabilmente
nei prossimi anni
cambierà ancora tante
e tantissime volte.
Nel 1975 c'era il mito del posto fisso,
il posto fisso in banca,
tutti si sposavano e il matrimonio
era la cosa più normale del mondo
e si viveva in un mondo
che era fatto di certezze.
Quelle certezze oggi
non ce le abbiamo più.
Le banche hanno iniziato
e continuano a licenziare.
Io ho scoperto sulla mia pelle
che il matrimonio non era per tutti,
anche se prima o poi,
Patrick, ce la facciamo.
Ho scoperto che i posti fissi
di colpo sparivano,
uno dopo l'altro,
un istante dopo l'altro.
E mentre alcuni di noi
imparavano a correre,
altri provavano a muovere
i primi passi.
C'è stata una sorta di inversione a U,
contromano in autostrada.
Tutto è cambiato,
il nostro mondo e cambiato,
ci siamo trovati
improvvisamente disorientati.
Nel 1998, avevo 23 anni,
ci si connetteva alla rete,
che proprio ieri ha compiuto
30 anni in Italia,
ci si connetteva con questi modem
un po' vecchi e impolverati,
qualcuno se lo ricorderà
quel rumore insopportabile:
"druuuuu druuuuu druuuuu",
una cosa stranissima.
Io nella mia camera,
vivevo ancora con i miei genitori,
ci mettevo un cuscino sopra, la sera,
per riuscire a connettermi
senza svegliare tutta la casa.
Nel 1998 non sapevo
quale sarebbe stata la mia vita
ma avevo imparato subito una cosa:
che devi continuare ad ascoltare,
a osservare,
e a imparare da quello
che stai ascoltando e osservando.
Ho iniziato nel 1998
la mia vita digitale
senza probabilmente ancora sapere
che sarebbe stata una vita digitale.
Vicino a Piazza Sant'Agostino a Milano
in un modesto ufficio,
insieme a un gruppo di persone
straordinarie e all'avanguardia,
ho realizzato il primo magazine italiano
totalmente su CD-Rom.
Quando internet era ancora poco diffuso,
c'era un CD-Rom dentro cui
noi avevamo messo interi mondi,
tantissimi video, interviste,
mi ricordo quando abbiamo realizzato
uno speciale a San Remo,
non dormivo notte e giorno
per riuscire a realizzare
e poi montare quelle interviste.
Ho trovato un'immagine un po' vecchia,
si chiamava Fantastic CD-Rom,
ed era una sorta di
gigantesco portale on line,
tutto appunto su questo CD
che potevi guardarti a casa.
Era talmente avanti che per funzionare
questo CD-Rom aveva bisogno
di un Pentium 386,
però nelle case degli Italiani all'epoca
c'erano al massimo i Pentium 286.
E così, dal fallimento
di quella esperienza,
8 mesi dopo questo
straordinario prodotto all'avanguardia
ha smesso di esistere.
Ecco, da quel momento
ho imparato la prima regola
che vorrei condividere con voi
questo pomeriggio.
Che è una regola
per me fondamentale
nella mia vita e nel digitale.
La regola è: "Be timely",
sii al posto giusto nel momento giusto.
A volte, essere troppo avanti
non ti porterà da nessuna parte.
Nel 2000 cosa stava accadendo?
In tanti quelli piu gufi,
quelli che speravano
che nulla si potesse evolvere,
credevano nel Millennium Bug.
Io credevo in qualcosa di diverso:
provavo a sperimentare
nuovi contenuti,
lo facevo su mezzi vecchi
e su mezzi nuovi.
Mi occupavo di quei messaggini
che arrivano allora
alle persone sul cellulare.
Dovevi mollare la fidanzata
e mandavi un messaggio
e ti arrivava in cambio un messaggio
per mollare la fidanzata o per fare
una dichiarazione d'amore.
Ecco, mi occupavo di quei contenuti,
mi occupavo di contenuti
di informazione per alcuni giornali
e realizzavo una trasmissione
radiofonica in cui le persone
si scambiavano il proprio
numero di cellulare
e abbiamo realizzato più di un matrimonio
grazie a quella trasmissione.
Una sorta di Tinder
dell'epoca, praticamente.
Molto prima che, come dire,
le applicazioni arrivassero
nel nostro mondo.
Sperimentando tutti quei contenuti
ho imparato una seconda cosa
che ci tengo a condividere
con voi oggi pomeriggio.
"Be useful".
Una regola fondamentale
del digitale, è "sii utile",
cerca di capire quali sono
i bisogni delle persone,
i bisogni espliciti, impliciti
ed anche latenti
e cerca di rispondere
ai bisogni delle persone.
Nel 2005, è stato un anno
importante per me,
ho compiuto 30 anni
finalmente uomo fatto e finito,
e ho pubblicato il mio primo libro,
che non è stato pubblicato
e che non era un libro.
Nel 2005, quando ancora
il "self-publishing"
non esisteva come termine,
e la prima piattaforma
di questo tipo
si iniziava intravedere in America,
sarebbe arrivata l'anno dopo poi
in Italia, si chiamava Lulu.
Io ho provato a fare quella cosa
senza ancora sapere cosa fosse,
e ho pubblicato su un sito internet,
non avendo un editore a disposizione,
la storia di tante persone
che provavano a capire
come affrontare questo nuovo mondo.
Era la storia di
"Generazione 1000 Euro".
Poi, dopo tante proposte editoriali,
è arrivata in libreria con Rizzoli.
Abbiamo fatto 7 edizioni straniere,
è diventato un film,
uscito sia in Italia che in Germania
e ha conquistato la prima pagina
del International Herald Tribune,
il quotidiano più importante al mondo,
per denunciare la situazione
che c'era in Italia.
E tutto questo è stato possibile
grazie al digitale.
E allora mi porto via una terza regola:
"Be a pioneer".
Segui la tua strada,
non ascoltare sempre solo gli altri,
e cerca di essere determinato
per raggiungere i tuoi obiettivi.
E così arriviamo al 2009,
era normale guardare i video su MTV
e YouTube era una cosa
che quasi nessuno ancora utilizzava.
3 decise di lanciare
il primo videofonino
e mi chiese di realizzare
una delle prime trasmissioni televisive
al mondo, pensate per il videofonino.
Si chiamava "Italian Job" e raccontavamo
le professioni nuove degli Italiani.
E lì ho imparato
un'altra regola, la quarta,
che voglio condividere con voi
qua a Tedx Padova oggi pomeriggio
che è: "Be everywhere".
E una regola fondamentale del digitale,
dobbiamo essere ovunque.
Dobbiamo essere dove le persone sono.
Così arriviamo al 2015.
Avevo perfettamente compreso
l'importanza della digital
Transformation, dell'open innovation,
facevo il manager, facevo il consulente,
e avevo una carriera brillante,
e ho deciso di riprendere la vita in mano
e giocare nuovamente con la vita.
Ho mollato le sicurezze,
sono entrato nel mondo di Talent Garden,
la più grande rete di co-working europea,
fondata da un ragazzo di 21 anni,
e con lui abbiamo creato
la Tag Innovation School,
la prima scuola del digitale in Italia,
per riuscire ad accompagnare le persone
in un mondo del lavoro
che c'è, che esiste,
che dà tante possibilità
a chi è preparato
per fare quelle professioni.
E quel che abbiamo fatto
era riuscire a trasmettere
agli altri una cosa importantissima,
che è trasformare
la propria passione in un lavoro.
Abbiamo portato in Italia
per la prima volta
il "Bootcamp Master" di 12 settimane
per formare da zero
i Junior Web Developer
una delle professioni oggi
più richieste dal mercato,
abbiamo fatto la stessa cosa
sul e-Commerce
sul UX Design, abbiamo spiegato
a chi fa Digital Marketing
che c'è un nuovo modo di farlo
col Growth Hacking,
ci siamo occupati del mondo dei dati,
e ci siamo dedicati anche ai più piccoli
con Coding Generation
per insegnare a programmare i videogame
anche ai ragazzi piccolissimi.
Ecco, mi porto a casa una quinta regola
da questa esperienza
che è: "Be open",
cioè sii pronto ad ascoltare,
a imparare, a guardare
cosa succede nel mondo
e fai queste cose molto velocemente.
La vita è un gioco,
la vita è una continua sfida
con se stessi, un continuo salto
e TEDx Padova ha voluto
intitolare questa giornata
"Let's play", ma "Let's play"
non è solo caratteristica di TEDx Padova,
è qualcosa che ci dobbiamo
portare dietro ogni giorno
che col digitale ha molto a che fare.
Il digitale è la nostra vita, il digitale
possiamo affrontarlo
se riusciamo a fare le cose giuste
al momento giusto,
se siamo utili agli altri,
se siamo di testa dura
e quindi riusciamo a essere dei pionieri,
se siamo ovunque con ciò che facciamo,
e se siamo aperti continuamente
all'innovazione e al cambiamento.
Ecco il digitale è,
prima di tutto, un approccio,
non è soltanto tecnologia,
è un modo di fare, un modo di pensare.
Digitale vuol dire
imparare a guardare oltre.
E quando si guarda oltre che cosa si fa?
Ci si riprende la propria vita in mano
e si ri-inizia a giocare,
perché il gioco più bello
è proprio costruire
ogni giorno con le nostre mani,
le nostre forze, le nostre energie,
la nostra vita.
(Applausi)